G
goodbye yeah not so fast the Kardashian
Jenner crew may have announced that
their hit reality show Keeping Up with
the Kardashians is ending after its 20th
season in early 2021 but now a source
tells e they aren't ruling out the idea
of doing other shows in the future tune
in because you never know what's going
to happen our source says the family is
busier than ever adding that all the
kids will continue to focus on more ways
to Branch out once the show is done the
family isn't ruling out a show or shows
in the future either but seriously can
someone just give Courtney and Scott to
six kid rain a show already I'm doing
pami yoga from peace be with me and I'm
doing the real one he's a freaking scen
dealer now and then everyone see you
later anyway the source adds that the
family plans to take some time off after
filming wraps but if they're offered
something that works for them and makes
sense they'll totally considerate quote
the family has become bigger than ever
and moving forward they can be selective
in the work they do they can have
control of their brand which they
weren't able to do when they first
signed on to do the show because no one
knew them we're normal we work I have to
get up every day and go to my store and
I there might be conflict you know along
the way but that's life you know keeping
up premiered on October 14th 2007 with
Ryan impressed as the executive producer
and when ET caught up with Ryan on
Wednesday he dished on the possibility
of getting more spin-offs from the
famous family I don't know the answer to
that we uh have not crossed that bridge
yet but I I do know that the family is
so grateful for having the opportunity
at e and having people um ride along
with them through relationships and
pregnancies and separations and breakups
I mean it's it's pretty cool to see that
they have been so vulnerable and open
and people have ridden along Ryan also
added that it wasn't easy for the family
to end their show after 14 years in
talking to the family this was a very
very hard decision for them to make and
and I know even you know before and
after the announcement came out they
were emotional we were trading texts and
emails after the announcement uh and you
look back at 14 years and 20 seasons of
a camera in your life and think about
that at some point you're going to say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're going to live with a little more
privacy in our lives and I think they
just felt like now is the time to do it
and all that Echoes what Kim's friend
Paris Hilton told ET that same day they
have huge business Empires I'm sure
that's what they want to spend their
time doing that and being with their
families you know I haven't spoken to
them about it so I don't know what the
reason was but I'm assuming they just
have so many things going on and you
know after 20
Seasons you know I think they're just
ready to live their life and not have to
be on camera every second as for the
possibility of future Kardashian shows
she doesn't doubt it because they have
one Fierce AF woman leading the fam
Chris is such a boss it makes me feel
incredibly proud I've known her since
we're little girls and the empires that
her her sisters her mother have built is
just amazing and I love them all so so
much and I just it's exciting to see
your friends do well and Chris well she
got emotional talking about the end of
an era on on air with Ryan Crest
Wednesday you're going to make me cry
all over again I think the number 20 you
know well it used to sound good until
2020 but the number 20 um it just seemed
like the right time I think for us to
take a minute and breathe and everybody
slow down a bit not slow down
professionally but just you know figure
out what our next steps are and all of
[Music]
that